In order to complete this first
challenge, I must first import
the classes I use to execute my
CRUD operations from lesson one.
I will import Base, Restaurant, and
MenuItem from my database_setup
file as well as create_engine and
sessionmaker from my sqlalchemy,
and sqlalchemy.orm libraries.
Along with my imports,
I must also add these four lines
of code to connect to my database.
Once again just copying
code written in lesson one.
Now, I will add another if statement to
my do get method, such that landing on
/restaurants lists out all of
the restaurants in my database.
Let's look at this new if statement.
Where I once looked for/hello, or
/hola, I am not looking for
the /restaurants path.
I then execute a query to get all
of the restaurants in the database.
My response codes are the same as with
my previous do_GET if statements.
But here, I execute a for-loop, and
add all of the restaurant menu
items to my output string.
Separate it with break lines, and
enclosed in my HTML and body tags.
I write the output to my wfile,
and send it off to the client.
When I save my code, and restart my
web server, I get an output like this.
When I visit local host
port 8080/restaurants,
it lists out all
the restaurants in my data base.
Objective one, complete.
See the instructor notes if you'd like
to see my code for objective one.